[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH VARGO: Today I want to talk
about four key areas in which
Google Cloud can help mobile
developers, desktop developers,
or any developer code
build, run, and observe
their applications better
using Google Cloud Platform.
And we're going to
focus on four key areas.
And there are other areas.
These are just the four that
we've chosen in the short 40
minutes that we have today.
The first is code.
We're going to talk about how
we can leverage Google Cloud
Services to build back-end
systems to support
our front-end mobile and
desktop applications.
Next, we'll talk about
how we can leverage
Google Cloud
artificial intelligence
and machine learning
technologies
to build intelligence
and business
logic into our applications.
Then we'll talk about how
you can build and publish
your applications leveraging
the power of the cloud.
And finally, after we've
published our applications,
we'll talk about how
we can gain insights
into how they're
performing and how they're
communicating with one another
by talking about observability.
In order to do this, my
colleague, Dale, and I
have come up with this idea
for a fictitious application.
It's a food delivery
application.
Now, we know there's many
food delivery apps out there,
but ours is going to
revolutionize the market.
Ours is specifically going to
leverage Google Cloud Platform
technologies.
And we're going to
use it to show you
how you can leverage those
technologies in your mobile
and desktop applications.
So let's go ahead and
jump over to the laptop,
and I'll show you a
quick demo of what
we've built here for you today.
I'm going to do
something super taboo.
I'm going to show an
iPhone and an IO demo.
Cool.
So I know this looks
like a movie recording,
but this is a real--
I'm using my iPhone, so you
all can see that this is real.
We have two apps here.
We have an app called gEats,
and an app called gEats Admin.
I'm going to show you
the gEats app first.
So I'm going to go ahead
and open up the gEats app.
And this is the application
we built here for you today.
It's actually built
using Flutter.
Can we get a shout
out for Flutter?
[CHEERING]
Sweet.
So even though I'm
using an iPhone,
this actually cross-compiled
to Android just fine
using the same exact code.
So what I'm going
to do here, is I'm
going to order from Googleplex.
Googleplex is our
fictitious restaurant
that we're working
with here today.
I'm going to add a Caesar
salad because I'm on a diet.
I'm going to add some grilled
cheese because I'm on a diet,
and cheesecake,
because I'm on a diet.
I don't know what kind
of diet y'all are on.
But I'm on a fun one.
So here I have my Caesar
salad, my cheesecake,
and my grilled cheese.
They're in my shopping cart.
And I'm going to go
ahead and click Checkout.
Now in order to
fulfill our narrative,
our application has had
some fraud in the past.
Specifically, people have stolen
friends' iPhones and Android
devices and ordered--
you know, it's the old order
10 pizzas to your house trick.
So what we've decided
to do as a product team
is implement a text
message verification.
So whenever I click
Send Confirmation,
my application will
generate a text message
with a total order cost.
It will send me that text
message, and then I have to--
oh, my mom said she loves me.
And then I have to reply yes
or no to this text message.
So we can see that
the order is $19.50.
We have a phone bug there.
It doesn't add
the zero after 50,
so you know this is
production ready.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm just going to
go ahead and reply yes.
And within a few seconds we'll
get a response back that says,
thank you for your order.
It will arrive soon.
And this is kind of the consumer
or the front-end application
we built, and it's a
mobile application.
So let's go out and
jump back to the slides.
And we'll talk about
the technologies we used
here specific to Google Cloud.
So if you've ever built
a mobile application--
that was our video,
in case it failed.
[CHUCKLING] We've
done this before.
So if you've ever built a mobile
application, especially using
Flutter, you know that we
use the standard material UI
components.
These are some stock images.
Nothing super complex there.
But if you've ever built a
mobile or desktop application,
you know that sending and
particularly receiving a text
message is very difficult.
While you might be able to
leverage the local phone
to send a message, you
don't have access outside
of the sandbox to
receive that message
and do any kind of
processing with it.
So this is where we
need to leverage a cloud
service in order to send and
receive those text messages.
And this provides a
perfect opportunity for us
to showcase the
first of many ways
in which Google Cloud
Platform has invested
in making the coding experience
for back-end services
and supporting services
quick and easy.
It all starts with code.
Whether you're a
mobile developer
or a desktop developer
or a firmware engineer,
it all starts with code.
And for the past year,
we've invested heavily
in the developer
tooling ecosystem
to bring you really great
developer experiences,
regardless of the technologies
you're working with.
Specifically, we don't want
you as a mobile developer
or an application developer
to have to provision servers,
create users, install packages,
install security updates.
We want to do all of that
for you as a cloud provider.
Some people call
this serverless.
It's the idea that
you give us your code,
and we run it for you.
We scale it for you, and we keep
it running for you while giving
you observability into it.
Let's go ahead and jump
back over to the laptop,
and I'll show you
exactly what we mean.
So here I have a very
small Node.js application.
It's about 100 lines of
code, 105 to be exact.
It uses the Express library.
And the important part is
that it has two endpoints.
The first endpoint is Send,
which you'll see right here.
This accepts input
from our application,
our mobile application.
It hits this Send endpoint,
which then communicates
with our third party API,
Twilio in this example,
to send a text
message to the user.
Then we have another
endpoint, which is Verify.
Verify receives a web
hook from our third party
API service whenever a user
responds to a text message.
It includes the body
of the text message.
And we can build branching
logic and process that response.
So you'll notice here we have
about three or four lines
of branching logic here where
we see, did the user say yes,
did the user say no.
And otherwise, we send them
in kind of a hot loop saying,
you've got to say yes
or no to this order.
Now this is obviously like
a fictitious application.
We don't actually dispatch an
order to the Googleplex Cafe,
because it doesn't exist.
But this gives you an idea
and hopefully some inspiration
as to how you could
leverage a service like this
to build something
very powerful.
But now what?
I have this Node.js code.
It's on my local laptop.
Now what do I do?
I obviously run Node
locally and install ngrok
and keep my laptop up in
production all the time.
That's probably
not a great idea.
So how can I get this code,
which is on my local laptop,
to be running somewhere
that my users can access it
and this third party
API can access it?
And this is where Google
Cloud Functions comes in.
So I'm going to go ahead
and change directory
into our code file here.
And inside here, you'll see--
let's do this.
Inside here, you'll see
our Node application.
And the important file
that I just showed
you is that index.js file.
That was the code that
we were just looking at.
Now I want to deploy this
code to a publicly accessible
endpoint.
And I can do that using
Google Cloud Functions.
So I'm going to show you
what this code looks like.
And I'm really bad at
typing live on stage,
so I've just typed this
out as a script in advance.
If you're not familiar
with scripting,
the first two lines just
say interpret this as bash.
The important part is the
gcloud functions deploy.
This uses gcloud, which
is the Google Cloud SDK.
You can install it on your
Mac, on your Windows device,
on your PC.
And we're deploying a
function called SMS.
This is kind of our SMS
gateway, if you will.
I'm specifying the project
in which to deploy it,
the run time.
In this example,
we're using Node.js.
We'll talk about some
other runtimes in a minute.
I'm giving it the entry
point where it should listen,
and finally, I'm telling
it to be an HTTP trigger.
There are other kinds of
triggers, like Pub/Sub.
But for this example,
we're using HTTP.
When I run this--
oops.
When I run this, the
gcloud deploy command
will bundle my code
for me locally.
It actually bundles
it into a tarball.
It sends that tarball up to the
Google Cloud Platform servers,
where the Google
Cloud Platform will
build a binary distribution
of our application
and run it for us.
And this is Google
Cloud Functions.
It's actually just
that easy to take code
that you have locally
on your laptop
and have it running at an
available HTTP endpoint
somewhere on the internet.
And by default, it doesn't
have any authentication.
But you can add your
own authentication,
either using your own frameworks
or using Google Cloud IAM,
Identity and Access Management.
So this is deploying.
It takes about two minutes.
Let's go ahead and jump
back to the slides.
And we'll talk about Google
Cloud Functions in more detail.
For this particular example,
we leveraged Google Cloud
Functions to deploy our
supporting back end SMS
service.
Our particular function
was written and Node.js,
but it could have been written
in Python or Go as well.
Node, Python, and Go
are the three languages
that we support today in
Google Cloud Functions.
And for many of you
in the audience,
you'll be excited to
know that we're currently
in a private alpha
for Java support.
So if you're leveraging
Java technologies,
you'll soon be able to
leverage those in Google Cloud
Functions.
But what if you don't
use those languages?
What if you're using
some other language--
Rust or Ruby-- or what if you
have additional requirements
beyond just 100 lines of code?
Maybe you do have some
system level dependencies.
Maybe you're interacting
with robotics
so you need the Robot Operating
System available to you.
Maybe you need access
to different things.
And this is why we introduced
Cloud Run just a few weeks ago
at Google Cloud Next.
Cloud Run is the latest edition
of our server offerings.
Remember, we talk
about serverless.
We mean don't
manage any servers,
don't install any packages.
With Cloud Run, you
package your application
and all of its dependencies into
this thing called a container
or a docker container.
And then Cloud Run scales
that container for you
automatically.
You run the gcloud command
to deploy your function
to Cloud Run.
Cloud Run will automatically
scale your function,
and it will even
scale it down to zero.
And this is very
important if you're
an early stage startup or
a mid-sized company that's
tight on a budget.
Because with Cloud
Functions and Cloud Run,
you will only pay while
your code is being run.
You don't pay if no one is
accessing that endpoint.
And if all of a sudden you
have a million users who
are all accessing
that endpoint, we'll
scale for you automatically.
And we'll automatically
scale back down
when that traffic alleviates.
That's code for you.
Now to tell you more about how
you can leverage AI and ML,
I'd like to invite my
colleague, Dale, onto the stage.
Please give it up for Dale.
[APPLAUSE]
DALE MARKOWITZ: Thanks, Seth.
Hi, I'm Dale.
I'm a developer for
AI and Google Cloud.
So let's talk about
how we can add
a little intelligence into our
app to make it easier to use.
And why might we
want to do that?
Well, you saw Seth's nice
Flutter app for ordering food.
But let's say that
you're a restaurant
and you want to get
listed on our app.
Oops.
Then you probably have a
menu that you need to upload.
And your menu is
probably analog,
so you need to have somebody
manually type in all
of the foods and prices, and
all of this metadata to become
listed in the gEats tool.
And that's really
annoying, especially
if you're trying to
do this on mobile.
So can AI help make that
part of our app easier?
Let me show you how.
Let's hop to the phone.
I'm clearly a pixel user.
All right, cool.
So you saw this nice
app that Seth built.
But let's look at the admin side
that a restaurant owner would
use.
As you can see in
this interface,
there's no text field for
writing foods or prices.
Instead, we just upload
a photo of our menu.
That photo gets uploaded
to the cloud and analyzed.
And that analysis can
take a few seconds.
So let me show you the
picture that I just uploaded.
It's this menu I was
holding on stage.
And as you can see, there's
lots of useful information
here, like the name of our cafe,
its address and phone number,
plus all of this
food information,
like the headings, salads,
mains, the food items
and their prices.
So let's hop back to the phone.
And, ah, look at that.
We got lots of
information from our menu
without even having
to type it in.
Let's take a look at it.
So we identified Googleplex
Cafe, its phone number
and address.
We also got these nice
little ratings stars,
and a map showing where
our restaurant's located,
and this cool user-generated
picture of the Google
headquarters.
We also did a pretty good
job of parsing the foods
on the menu, the descriptions--
veggie burger on a pretzel bun.
I also want to point out that
this part wasn't 100% perfect.
We didn't identify the
price of the chili,
or we thought that
cherry-lime was a food and not
a type of gelato.
But we still saved
a lot of time.
And we can always go in and
edit those specific details.
So how did we make
that possible?
Let's head back to the slides.
So let's just recap
what just happened.
First, I uploaded a photo.
Then we took the photo
and extract it into text.
Then we determined the
location, the rating,
and we pulled some photos.
And then we also parsed
the menu itself, the foods
and their prices.
So how did we do it?
To get the text, we used
the Google Vision API.
And once we had our
menu in text format,
we could pass it to the
Google Natural Language API.
This tool has lots of
useful functionality
for analyzing text.
But we just focused on the
entity extraction feature,
which finds substrings
in our menu text
that correspond to prices, phone
numbers, addresses, and more.
And once we extracted
that phone number,
that was very useful
because we could use it
to query the Google Places API.
So Google will take
a phone number,
and if it recognizes that
that phone number corresponds
to a place, it can return
you useful metadata
like the star rating
of the restaurant,
user-generated photos,
location, and more.
But actually, the most difficult
part about building this app
was identifying those
menu-specific entities
like that "grilled
cheese" was a food,
and that "on a pretzel bun"
was a description of a food.
Because that's so specific
to our context of menu
parsing that there's nothing
in the box in a Google API
that recognizes these terms.
For that, we had to
build a custom model.
And we did that using a tool
called Google Cloud AutoML.
The way that works is you upload
a labeled training data set.
AutoML builds a model
for you, and then it
hosts your model in
a REST API that you
can call to get predictions.
But rather than explain this,
let me just show you a demo.
Let's hop to the laptop.
So here I am in the Google
Cloud Platform console.
And I'm in the Natural
Language AI tool space.
And there are lots of
different types of text models
that we could build.
But we're going to build
an entity extraction model.
That's for identifying
inline text items.
So our first step is to find
a data set and upload it.
And I tried a few, and
this one worked the best.
And so what happened
was I found this data
set provided by
the New York Public
Library of pictures
of historical menus
that had been uploaded.
And I used the Vision API to
extract the text from them.
So let me show you
what that looked like.
Easy Beef, a
restaurant in Virginia.
And then I went in
and I hand-labeled
all of the entities
that I cared about.
I just did that by clicking and
dragging, and then saying, ah,
a cheeseburger is a food.
And after I did this
for about two hours,
I got really bored
of labeling data.
This is the very boring part
of building machine learning
models.
But luckily, Google now offers
a data labeling service,
where if you want a
data set like this
you can send it to
the labeling service.
Google will label your data,
and then you'll be good to go.
One thing I'll also
point out is that I
didn't have a ton of menus to
work with in that data set,
only under 200.
And ideally, when you're
building a model like this,
you really want more like 1,000.
But as people use our app
we'll collect more data.
So that's fine for now.
Now we want to
train a model to be
able to do that annotation
for us automatically.
And that's actually
the easiest part.
We just click Start
Training, and then we'll
get a popup that says
something to the tune of,
all right, come
back in four hours
and you can see your model.
And then behind
the scenes, Google
will train a model for us.
If we hop into this
Evaluation tab,
we can see all sorts
of useful metrics
about how accurate
our model was.
And, like I said, more
data means more accurate.
So hopefully, over time
our model will improve.
And then in the
Test and Use tab,
we can actually
make predictions.
So I think I opened
this because I couldn't
write a menu on the fly.
But I came up with
this little fake menu.
I'll press Predict, and we'll
see if our model can correctly
identify the entities.
And as you can see, it
identified all of the entities
imperfectly because
that's machine learning,
and machine learning has an
element of probability to it.
But if we were to
use this in our app,
it actually does save us a lot
of time inputting data, right?
Because it identified
most of the foods.
It missed potato chips,
but it was pretty good.
And then as users
correct us in the app,
we'll have more data
to retrain our model.
By the way, this is how we
use the app in the console.
But you can also hit
it with a REST API
or through a number
of client libraries.
All right.
Let's hop back to the slides.
I just showed you how to build
an entity extraction model.
But actually, there are
AutoMLs for all sorts
of different data types like
photos, video, and more.
And if you want to
learn more about this,
make sure to check out my
session tomorrow at 12:30.
But with that, I'll
hand it back to Seth.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thank you, Dale.
So far, we have showed you
how Google Cloud enables
you to focus on your
code by deploying
scalable back-end services using
Cloud Functions or Cloud Run.
And Dale just showed us
how to add intelligence
to our applications by
leveraging Google Cloud ML
products like AutoML.
And I have to say that
I'm an engineer that
focuses on infrastructure
and operations.
And prior to this
talk, I had no idea
about anything other
than machine learning,
besides Magic.
And Dale has taught
me a lot about how
we can leverage
different Google Cloud
technologies without a
PhD in machine learning.
And I feel like an expert now.
I'm not, but I feel
like an expert.
So next let's look at how
Google Cloud can help us
with our builds, specifically
our mobile application builds.
So we have this Android
application code.
Again, this is Flutter,
but it could be anything.
And we have these AI models.
Now what?
How do I get that in
the hands of my users?
Now I could leverage something
like the Android Build Studio
locally on my MacBook.
That would build my application.
I could publish it to
the Google Play Store.
But my local laptop is not
a hermetic environment.
I might have packages or
users or configurations that
will cause my build to fail--
or worse, pass incorrectly by
linking to a system library
or using the wrong
version of Java
or the wrong version of
the Android SDK or NDK.
We don't want this.
Especially if you have a
many different developers,
especially across many
different organizational units,
you want a consistent
central build environment,
where you can control things
like versions, variables,
substitutions,
packages, et cetera.
And this is where Cloud
Build can come in.
Cloud Build enables us to
use the scale and elasticity
of the cloud to
build and publish
our Android applications.
With Cloud Build we can build
and test our applications
in isolated hermetic
environments,
leveraging the scale and
elasticity of the cloud.
Most importantly, we only
pay for the build time
that we're using, and there's
a very generous free tier
to get started.
So with that, let's go ahead
and jump over to the laptop,
and I'll show you
exactly what we mean.
So I'm going to go up here
to my build directory.
So in here I have an
Android application
that's built using Gradle.
Now I totally could open
this up in Android Studio.
I could click Build.
I could deploy it to a phone.
And I bet that many
of you in the audience
have already done that before.
But how do I get this in
the hands of my users?
Well, I could build it
locally using the Android
Studio with a production build.
But I want to leverage
the power of the cloud.
For me to build this locally
takes about 10 to 15 minutes
with my dual Core i7s.
But what if I could use, say,
32 cores to build this app?
That would hopefully
be very fast.
But at the same
time, it guarantees
that nothing on
my local laptop is
interfering with the
build, having it bit fail
or pass improperly.
So let me show you how we
submit our Android build
to Cloud Build.
Just like before,
I have a script,
because I'm not good
at typing on stage.
Let's jump down
to the very bottom
where we have
gcloud build submit.
We're running a build
by submitting all
of this code in this directory.
All of these Android manifests
and [? Gradle ?] [? loop ?]
files, we're sending all
of that up to Cloud Build.
We're running our build
on a high CPU 32 core VM,
and then we're passing
in some substitutions.
What are these substitutions?
Well, in order to
build an Android
application we need
the Android NDK--
or we need the entered SDK,
and potentially the NDK.
But every time I
build my application,
I don't want to recompile
the entire Android SDK.
I don't want to have to
download it, and install
it and all of the dependencies.
With Cloud Build,
what I can do is
I can cache those different
layers of my build steps.
So I can download, say,
the Android SDK 27.
I can cache that
as a build layer.
And then when I'm ready
to deploy my application,
I pull that build layer down,
and I just build against it.
And then anyone else
in my organization
that's building
Android applications
builds against the same base
layer, the same base image.
And that guaranteed
some consistency
across our applications.
I'm going to go ahead
and run this now.
Now there are three machine
types for Cloud Build.
[? We ?] have a single core,
an 8 core and, in this example,
the 32 core.
I ran this particular build
across all three instance
types.
It takes about 15 minutes
on the single core,
about three minutes
on the 8 core,
and about two minutes
on the 32 core, which
is what we're using here today.
But I don't think you
all want to stand here
and watch logs stream
for two minutes.
So let's go ahead and
jump back to the slides.
We might come back
to this output
if we have time in a bit.
So let's recap
what just happened.
I have an Android
application code.
I submit that code
to Cloud Build.
And Cloud Build can
build anything--
Ruby applications,
Python applications.
Today we're building
an Android application.
Cloud Build not only
compiles my application,
but it also runs any
tests that I have for me.
Then it uploads the
compiled APK file
to Google Cloud Storage,
which is our object store.
From there, you can download it,
load it onto your test devices,
give it out to trusted
users for feedback.
What we didn't do
in our example today
is publish directly to
the Google Play Store.
However, you could use
the Google Play Store
APIs to publish directly
to a beta or test channel
on the Google Play Store.
And on the other
side, Cloud Build
actually integrates with source
control like GitHub, and Git,
and supports these
concepts of build triggers.
So you can imagine
a world where you
build a CI/CD pipeline for
your Android applications,
such that when you
merge a pull request
or merge a change request,
within 10 to 15 minutes
that change is available as
a beta build to your users,
all in an automated
fashion, only paying
while your build is running.
This is truly leveraging
the power of cloud.
But now what?
We have our application.
It's into production.
Hopefully, we have some users.
Right now, the gEats
app is really popular.
There's two users.
It's Dale and I. But now what?
We're done, right?
No.
We have to talk
about observability.
How do we gain insights and
metrics into our application?
So let's come up with another
hypothetical scenario.
Or sorry, let's talk
about observability first.
What is this thing
that I'm saying?
I'm saying this word--
"observability."
Observability is
an umbrella term
that describes things like
monitoring, logging, alerting,
tracing, dashboards,
and much more.
It allows us to gain insights
into a single application,
but also how our
applications are
communicating with one another.
So now let's look at a
hypothetical situation.
Let's say on social media
we get a message like this.
"Hey, I really love your
new food delivery app.
But sometimes it's
really, really slow
to get my text message.
Sometimes it takes nearly
five minutes to arrive,
and I'm really hungry."
Now as an application developer
who's generally internet savvy,
I could quickly write this off.
Clearly, they're
not in a good cell--
they don't have good
cell phone reception.
That could explain
the latency, right?
Or maybe it's an issue with
their cellular provider,
in general.
Maybe it just takes their
cellular network provider time
to deliver.
Or maybe they have an old phone,
can't process the messages
fast enough.
But what if I could
actually prove it?
What if I could get a message
like this from my support
team or my social team,
and I could definitively
go back to them and say, "Nope.
This is definitely
not our problem.
This relies somewhere
else outside of the chain
that we don't control."
And in order to do that, we
can leverage a tool called
Google Cloud Stackdriver.
Stackdriver is a tool
for observability.
It provides integrated
logging, monitoring, alerting,
and tracing across
Google Cloud that
allows us to gain better
insights into our application's
performance.
Let's go ahead and jump into the
autogenerated Stackdriver trace
dashboard to confirm that
our text messages are
being processed quickly.
So let's go ahead and jump
over to the demo laptop.
Here I have the Google
Cloud trace dashboard
in our web console.
And I'm particularly filtering
on an endpoint, which
I've coincidentally named "slow"
for the purposes of this demo.
Now I realize that some
of you may not understand
what you're looking at.
So give me a moment
to explain it.
First, we're looking
at the past hour
of traces, which is a measure
of the different steps
that our code is taking
across our different services.
On the left- hand side, we're
looking at a data point,
a sample of a data point.
And on the y-axis,
it's the latency,
or the total time it took
that request to fulfill.
So a dot here, for example,
took 20,000 milliseconds.
That's 20 human seconds.
Whereas a dot down here
took 340 milliseconds.
That's less than half
one human second.
Now we can look at
this, and we can
see that most of
our requests are
down here at the very
bottom, which is good.
It means they're being
processed very quickly.
Ideally, we want low,
low, low latency.
So we can see that
most of our requests
are being processed in about
300 to 400 milliseconds, which
is really good considering
that's a mobile application
going over the public internet,
invoking our endpoint, which
is communicating with
a third party API,
and then returning a response.
So 500 milliseconds
for that round trip
is really, really good.
You'll notice that
we have a few here
that are about 3 or 4 seconds.
But those don't concern me.
That could just be
network latency.
But these ones up here,
that's concerning to me.
Those are definite outliers.
They're 20 times
and 40 times longer
than any of our other traces.
So let's take a look
at the difference here.
Maybe we can gain some
insights into our code.
If I look at one of these
traces that took about 300
milliseconds-- scroll
down a little bit--
you can see that our
endpoint was dispatched.
Then about 5 milliseconds
later, 10 milliseconds later,
it actually hit our code.
And then about 3
milliseconds later, we
dispatched our third party API.
Very quick, very
fast, very expedient.
Now let's take a look at one
of these outliers up here.
Now we notice something
very interesting.
Our request, again,
dispatched very quickly.
There's only a few
milliseconds between when
we hit our endpoint and when our
function was actually invoked.
But then there's a huge block
of time, almost 20 seconds,
until we call our
third party API.
This is actually
an indication to me
that our initial
hypothesis is wrong.
This is a bug in our code.
We're not waiting for
the third party API.
We're not waiting
on network latency.
This is all within
my application.
And I know that it's happening
inside the SMS slow endpoint.
This gives me immediate
insights into where
to go to look in my code for
a bug or a performance issue.
So let's take a look at that.
And it turns out if we jump
down here to our slow endpoint,
there's actually a
random 10% of the time
we sleep for 20 seconds.
And there's a really
embarrassing to-do here,
that I was supposed
to remove this
before going to production.
And this was just
for local testing.
And then we send a test message.
And now I know no
one in the room
has ever accidentally pushed
local test code to production.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you had,
hopefully it's clearer
how a tool like
Stackdriver Trace
made it easy and apparent
that this was our fault.
And we can go to our support
team, and we can say,
hey, your users are right.
10% of the time, we were making
them wait 20 extra seconds.
We fixed that.
It's not going to happen again.
And we built monitoring
and alerting around it
so that we can proactively
detect it in the future.
Let's go ahead and jump
back to the slides.
So to recap, today we
discussed four areas
in which Google Cloud Platform
can improve your developer
experience.
First, we talked about code.
We talked about how
you can leverage tools
like Cloud Functions
and Cloud Run
to build scalable serverless
applications to support
your mobile or desktop apps.
Next, we talked about leveraging
Google Cloud artificial
intelligence and machine
learning products
to build intelligence
into your applications
without needing a PhD in natural
language processing or machine
learning.
Then we showed how we can
leverage the power of the cloud
to build our applications
on multicore VMs,
leveraging elasticity in
a hermetic and isolated
environment.
And then lastly, once our
application was ready to go,
we saw how we can diagnose
and analyze that application
when it's in the
hands of our users
by tracing our back-end services
leveraging Stackdriver Trace.
This has all been in service
of one high-level goal.
And if you're going to take
anything away from this session
today, this is what Dale and
I want you to leave with,
is that you should
focus on your code
and let Cloud do
the heavy lifting.
We are investing
resources in making sure
that we are not getting in
the way of your core business.
We want to support the business
with these different tools
and technologies.
Let Cloud do the heavy lifting.
If any of this was
interesting to you,
I'd like to invite you to
attend our other Cloud sessions.
You can click on
Cloud in the app
or on the mobile web interface.
Specifically, I want to
highlight these four sessions.
For a general overview of
many different Google Cloud
Services, check us out on
stage 7 at 2:30 tomorrow.
As Dale already said, she
has a talk later tomorrow
about training a custom machine
learning model without any data
science experience required.
If you're concerned about
the security aspects of this,
there's a really
great session tomorrow
at 4:30 talking about how you
can secure your applications
while leveraging Google Cloud.
And if you are at all interested
in that serverless stuff--
Google Cloud Functions,
Google Cloud Run, App Engine,
App Engine Flex--
there's a great session
tomorrow at 6:30
on making the
right decisions for
your serverless architecture.
So with that, I'd like to thank
you all very much for coming.
Dale and I will be happy to
take questions in the sandboxes
down here on the stage or feel
free to tweet at us as well.
Thank you all so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]